Stanley Kubrick Robert Altman Stanley
Kubrick Altman Kubrick Altman Kubrick
auckman kubrickman Stanley kubright
Roberts Robert what
[Music]
today we are going to be debating who is
the greatest director of all time
my name is Jeremy white I'm representing
Stanley Kubrick
from Lionel I'm going for Robert Altman
this debate will have one opening
statement Three Sixty Second rounds a
final closing statement and one [ __ ]
flag per side I'm not gonna lie I'm a
little intimidated I don't know let's go
opening statement
who is the greatest director of all time
you'll have 30 seconds Robert Altman and
the reason why I say Robert Altman is
because I think he's the most
artistically diverse filmmaker the
movies that he [ __ ]
it's just 30 seconds I haven't even
started I haven't even started this is
the first question what are you doing
[ __ ] this is just a strategy he's
doing to throw me off my game go ahead
go ahead you know what you can have that
that's part of your strategy you can
take it that's fine
opening statement
who is the greatest director of all time
you have 30 seconds first I have to
explain what a great director is to me
which is somebody who can make a film
about really really complex themes but
make it digestible and kind of simple
for an audience while also making it
riveting so I think Stanley Kubrick is
absolutely the best at doing that and I
think that Stanley Kubrick while not
perhaps the most versatile director is
far more
versatile than
about the light you're gonna say 2001 is
digestible for everyone to watch a kid
can watch 2001 and be like I love this
digestible and appropriate for children
are two very different things
round one distinct style and trademarks
you have 60 seconds Stanley Kubrick's
style is his themes he uses his imagery
he started out as a photographer
documentary filmmaker and has made some
of the greatest imagery and film that I
know of and he also uses music unless I
believe the first two use music in a way
that wasn't just a suggestion to the
audience of how they should feel or like
a decorative piece for the film but it
was truly like an accompaniment I think
Paul Thomas Anderson said something like
that
um
he
his style his um well 60 seconds is long
you talk too fast I do talk too fast
um but I really do I believe that how
specific he is uh with his work
um period specific uh he's a true uh
perfectionist in all different genres
[Music]
round one distinct style and trademarks
example talking points is conceptual
mind and ability to think outside of the
box creative cinematography choices
unique storytelling abilities you'll
have 60 seconds well that's easy because
you just said everything when he was
explaining the question everything he's
done he's the way that he uses sound in
his movie is so natural in California
splits the way that it's all like it
just feels like you're actually in there
it's the best sound design where you
hear natural conversations the opening
of that where you're watching all these
different poker games and then it lands
on the one and you can hear that
conversation clearly while you're
hearing all the chatter that feels like
not just background noise
when he did from like images to
California split to the longer buyers
all in one those are three wildly
different movies made in such a short
like time spent they're not you're doing
this you want to call [ __ ] on that I
don't know about it so wildly images is
like a full-on psychological Thriller
it's nothing like along goodbye it's
nothing like California split okay it's
nothing and then he also made Popeyes
which was a crazy movie which was a
crazy swing he made a big Studio Movie
so I don't know he's just been off and
then you have what else uh the player
he's he's
Nashville's all improv damn it so many
thoughts come to you at once and you
don't think about it I can tell that you
looked up Robert Altman on IMDb you were
able to list four or five of his films
and I heard you talk a lot about sound
design which is an important part of
filmmaking but when it comes to the big
picture in a film I don't necessarily
think of of sound design first I think
of story I think of themes I think of
even cinematography so I think it's
interesting that your first instinct was
to go to uh sound design because I was
talking because specifically I was
talking about how his movies feel
natural the opposite of cool brick
whereas just his movies feel it's like
he was so focused on the technical side
of things Rose Altman was the opposite
where he's like Rogue and just free and
so that's why I called him artistically
diverse because he just did what he want
off the Instinct yes without perfecting
I will agree I do I love Altman and I
think you're you're absolutely right
there was like an improvisational like
aspect to how he got his performances to
his camera work and he let the whole
world really exist I love Robert Altman
but there's just so much like Perfection
and purpose behind every single shot and
every single moment in a Kubrick film
round two breath of work you will have
60 seconds I'm gonna talk a little bit
slower this time okay
after Lolita I believe that Kubrick made
maybe seven films after Lolita and I
believe six out of eight of those are
masterpieces and that can almost not be
denied
um and they're all over the place it is
Lolita it's Barry Linden it's full metal
jacket it's Dr Strangelove it's really
like all over the map The Shining and
the horror 2001 and sci-fi it really
like crosses the the spectrum of all
different sorts of genres and when you
talk about influence I mean every
Jonathan Glazer Paul Thomas Anderson
Stephen Spielberg there's almost like no
incredibly accomplished director living
today that hasn't cited Kubrick as a as
a huge and massive influence in their
work
27 Academy Award nominations I believe
it was
well somebody did a lot of research I
did some research yeah okay fine
this round is all about Altman's overall
body of work you will have 60 seconds
okay
so I will say the difference while
Kubrick was more intentional with the
amount of movies he made it was smaller
I do I I mean I think that goes into
part with Altman whereas he wasn't so
precious and he was just like making
things and he wanted to find something
that just felt real like Matt well Matt
he you talk about Kubrick going through
all these different like genres the only
one that Altman didn't do was I guess
sci-fi because Mash is a like a satire
on Army and then California split also
is considered the greatest gambling
movie of all time probably Elliott gold
in him the longer buys a great Noir and
then he made shortcuts which also was
highly influential to Baltimore
Sanderson as well
um I think you can see his DNA and a lot
of stuff that's come out like more
recently to where people are now going
back to him obviously saftis
um it's all over the place and now this
light just threw me off for a second but
that's okay because I'm not done yet
[Music]
look it's really difficult for me
because I I agree with you Robert Altman
is a really wonderful filmmaker and
you're right like he he seemed to have
like to an extent like a bit more of
like a creative motor maybe like he he
had to get things out there but if
you're going like Masterpiece To
Masterpiece in my opinion it doesn't
compete which would you say is Kubrick's
Masterpiece he doesn't just have one so
you wouldn't say there's one Masterpiece
that people refer to I think 2001
Clockwork
Shining
Full Metal Jacket
um doctor Strangelove those would be my
top five and in something like that
order yes but then can you name five
masterpieces for maltman by the way
Nashville
um mash the long goodbye shortcuts
and
I mean people would probably say
Masterpiece I'm talking about
masterpieces you wouldn't say those
movies are masterpieces no no I'm just
making sure that you know what you're
gonna say next I know what I'm saying
okay I know what I'm saying say you're
trying to throw me off right now by the
way I know I'm I'm doing an uphill
battle right I just know you're reaching
and that's what's [ __ ] yeah what am
I reaching about what specifically
because you're trying to name a fifth
you're naming
I said four it's upside down
I can't read upside down
it says [ __ ] whatever I said the
player no you didn't I thought I set the
player I swear I thought I set the
player I'm so mad because that was the
one I said I'll set the player so what's
up California's splitting the player in
my favorites yeah I know I'm so mad that
I thought I said that oh my God
Nashville before the player Nashville is
a three-hour movie that's all improv I
think that's crazy I think that's so
tight
round three influence and Legacy you
have 60 seconds okay so uh Kubrick when
we talk about uh directors and
influences like I already mentioned we
had PTA we had Jonathan glace we had
Stephen Spielberg and I I think I
mentioned those directors because
Spielberg obviously done a lot of sci-fi
I I really think without 2001 and I
would even argue Clockwork Clockwork uh
sci-fi could exist in the way it does
today or these like films about
dystopian Futures and stuff like that
Clockwork was I'm gonna call [ __ ]
immediately come on explain yourself
dude you ever heard of this movie called
what is that called Metropolis
sure Sci-Fi movies that existed that
influenced him still
for sci-fi
Moore 2001
hey this is what you did to me I know
I'm stuck now
um influences influences Zeitgeist okay
so even a film like Eyes Wide Shut which
is a movie that I didn't understand when
I first watched it but have watched it
more recently and really enjoy just
think about the way that it's it's
affected like culture and the Zeitgeist
right this was one of his most or least
popular films and it's mentioned all the
time Eyes Wide Shut parties people
mentioned Eyes Wide Shut masks have you
been to a housewife [ __ ] party I haven't
been to one but I know they're out there
and that's because of Stanley Kubrick
yeah
this round is all about the legacy of
Altman as a director you will have 60
Seconds
I don't need 60 seconds I only need to
say one movie
and how it influenced this other movie
that's influenced everybody
shortcuts Magnolia
that's all I have to say hmm
that's all I have to say that's all I
have to say so let me make sure I
understand this correctly
so you said that Magnolia has influenced
every other film Paul Thomas Anderson
has I'm talking about what you said fine
fine you make me articulate myself I'm
saying shark I'm saying Robert Altman
influenced a director who's very
influential yeah he's he's every he's
the one behind he's every director's
favorite director
yeah Kubrick was the one that he was
everyone he is favorite director
it's not Kubrick I actually don't know
it's not Kubrick it's not it's not
Kubrick I call Bush how is the rest of
my time to say [ __ ] and hold this up
it's not who is it all right we're in
the weeds
closing statement you'll have 30 seconds
all right here we go I do believe that
Stanley Kubrick has influenced more
directors even gifted directors we're
talking about Spielberg we're talking
about PTA we're talking about Lars von
true we're talking about some of the
greatest directors of our time have all
cited Kubrick as if not their very
favorite director perhaps the most
influential director for them so if all
of these directors that living today
have been influenced so greatly by
Stanley Kubrick how can Kubrick not be
the greatest director
I need to make a song case there very
strong case I have nothing else I just
want you on the cliff
this is your last chance to defend
Robert Altman you will have 30 seconds
I call him the greatest not because of
his body of work but the inspiration of
the freedom of what he does if you're a
director and you get into movies you
don't skip over Robert Altman you look
at his work and you see how diverse it
is and you like oh this man just made
what he felt and I think that's what's
more influential than Stanley Kubrick
going geeking out technical over like
making lenses for this specific thing
yeah we know he's great we all know that
whatever we're getting past that we're
going off something that you can't
that you can't
that you can't quite grasp with words
it's just a Feeling by the way I just
want to say for the record I don't think
Robert Altman is a better director than
Stanley Kubrick but
wait a minute
but
but sorry
we're going to edit that out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I don't want to say the words out loud
because I hate losing but I do know that
Kubrick is better than Altman I'm so
happy I love Robert Altman I love you
Lionel I'm happy to to shake on it as
long as you know that I want see I don't
we don't need these caveats we can just
shake on it and say Well done I guess
well let me ask you this who will make a
better episode of the bear
yeah go ahead and hold your head in
shame because you know the answer go
ahead and say it out loud so we can all
hear it in this studio I do believe
Robert helpman would make a better
episode of the bearer than Stanley
Kubrick thank you of course
[Music]